michael saylor the ceo of microstrategy
one of the longest-standing ceos of a
publicly traded company announced that
microstrategy has purchased an
additional
5050 bitcoin for approximately
242.9 million dollars in cash at an
average price of forty eight thousand
ninety nine dollars per bitcoin and as
of september twelfth they hold
approximately 114
42 bitcoins which they acquired for just
over three billion dollars at an average
price of twenty seven thousand seven
hundred and thirteen dollars per bitcoin
so michael saylor has purchased another
5 000 bitcoin he spent about 243 million
bucks they now hold
over 114 000 they spent 3.16 billion on
it average purchase price 27 000
absolutely incredible we are watching
the single greatest public market trade
of our lifetime either this will work
out incredibly well a microstrategy will
likely become one of the most valuable
companies in the world
or it will all
evaporate
into thin air and everyone who is a
critic will say we tell just how guess
what i think it's gonna work so we'll
see what happens here this is a
quintessential speculative attack what
does that mean a speculative attack
which was made famous by pierre roshard
basically the idea is you go and you
borrow a depreciating asset cash and you
take that depreciating asset of fiat
cash and you use it to buy sound money
which is bitcoin and then what you are
essentially doing is you're borrowing
with a cost of capital somewhere in the
ballpark he's borrowed at .75 percent he
borrowed at zero and he's borrowed at
six or seven percent as well this does
not look like it was borrowed capital
this is balance sheet capital that
they're using here i believe in order to
go ahead and make this purchase so
you're using balance sheet plus you're
using the debt and you're continuing to
acquire bitcoin as far as i know
publicly uh you've got the winklevoss
twins who own 210 000 bitcoin right now
microstrategy has 114 000 bitcoin do we
think that michael saylor will be able
to buy enough bitcoin to eventually
eclipse what the winklevoss twins had i
don't know but that's an interesting
thing to watch 210 000 versus 114 000 he
owns today now remember michael saylor
as he's continued to spend three plus
billion dollars to buy bitcoin has
become somewhat of a expert or a
luminary to other public company ceos he
held a conference uh earlier this year
for ceos and cfos of large publicly
traded companies and said if you would
like to learn about how we did it if
you'd like to see the playbook we will
go ahead and open source that we will
show you how we did this one of the
people who has talked to michael saylor
and decided to go ahead and buy bitcoin
was elon musk and if you go back to
december of last year there was this now
infamous or famous exchange between elon
and michael saylor elon said are such
large transactions even possible talking
about buying a significant portion of
the tesla balance sheet in bitcoin and
michael saylor said yes i've purchased
over 1.3 billion in bitcoin in past
months and would be happy to share my
playbook with you offline from one
rocket scientist to another pretty damn
cool now as we look at this elon musk
obviously went out he spent about 1.5
billion dollars on bitcoin uh and he
bought it somewhere in the 33 to 35 000
range michael saylor obviously has
bought at ten eleven thousand dollars
he's bought at almost fifty thousand
dollars the guy just keeps buying
absolute savage and so at the time in
december he'd spent 1.3 billion now he
has spent over 3 billion dollars so more
than doubled his position this year in
bitcoin we've got this chart that came
from willy woo legend in on chain
analytics that shows the bitcoin held by
public companies and if we kind of zoom
in here a little bit what you can see is
that the bitcoin held by all corporates
continues to go up a big portion of that
obviously is micro strategy there you
can see uh they are by far the the big
leader and then you've also got tesla
galaxy digital shout out to mike
novogratz and square jack dorsey doing a
great job as well and so as we continue
to see not only the existing players
like microstrategy tesla galaxy digital
square and others including the bitcoin
miners that are publicly traded
we continue to also see new entrants
doing this and so all corporates
continue to go up which is pretty
incredible now the last thing that i
will say about this is eric weiss who
many of you may not know eric is michael
saylor's friend they've been friends for
a long time eric is actually probably
the number one person who had an impact
on getting michael saylor to go from
somewhat of a critic of bitcoin early in
the early 2010s to eventually seeing the
potential and going ahead and starting
to make this purchase and so eric
tweeted today he said 400 days ago
microstrategy owned zero bitcoin
they've effectively purchased 11.8
bitcoin per hour that's one bitcoin
every five minutes for the last 400 days
absolutely incredible when you start to
actually look at the data around this
and understand how quickly they've been
able to build this position and how
significant the position is today over
three billion dollars of cash in and if
you go ahead and you look at what the
value of 114 000 bitcoin is today it's a
lot more than 3 billion
joe john what do we think about this
i mean he's a certified legend like it's
absurd at this point uh
that tweet right there is a perfect
example right 400 days ago he didn't own
any and the one thing i always think
back to is like
the greatest strength i think that he
did was when everyone else was kind of
counting it out uh we saw it appreciate
in value a ton from 2017 in that bull
market and then come crashing back down
and he missed the entire thing right he
didn't own any bitcoin and for the last
400 days he basically has implemented a
strategy to acquire as much as he
possibly could his cost basis is higher
now than it ever was during that bull
run of 2017. obviously the price is
appreciated so he's uh done
exceptionally well from there but look
at the end of the day he has turned a
500 million dollar company into a six
billion dollar company so that's
obviously impressive and he set himself
up to make one of the single greatest
bets of all time if this plays out the
way that he believes it will so we'll
see kind of at the end of the day uh
where this goes price-wise but when it
comes down to his concentrated bet i
don't know if i've ever seen anyone make
this much of a concentrated bet this
quickly and have this much belief in a
single asset
john what do you think
he's a gangster for sure
he is i also just realized that uh
michael sailor michael strategy same
initials company and name which is
pretty cool
[Music]
to say but no i think first of all he
has an average price of around 28 000 of
coin as he continues to acquire
thousands and thousands of coins at a 40
000 plus uh which speaks to how he's
kind of spread it out over time i'm
curious is is his end game just to like
make money on this because i don't see
him doing anything or a lot of things at
least publicly with the infrastructure
part of bitcoin it seems like he's just
kind of holding it putting on his
balance sheet and uh waiting for the
price to go up if and probably never he
will never sell it
i mean
i believe i don't want to speak for
michael himself but my understanding is
that it's like a money play no that he
believes that he will never sell the
bitcoin back into dollars that he will
hold the bitcoin and that will end up
being very very important that's why i
say that microstrategy if you look today
and you said to me pick a company
that is nowhere near the most valuable
company in the world but i think has a
chance to get there microstrategy is
probably that company i mean if you go
ahead and you look at the microstrategy
stock um if i just pull up real quick
today they are a
5.9 almost 6 billion company and if we
look year to date their stock price was
at 425 at the beginning of the year
today it's at 600 bucks if you go all
the way back a year ago uh in september
it was 159
right so call it 150 bucks and what
you've watched is you've watched their
stock 400 percent increase at one point
it was as high as over a thousand
dollars so you know
if bitcoin hits a million dollars he has
about roughly 100 what is it 115 000
bitcoin right now that's 115 billion
dollars this company is currently a six
billion dollar company
so right if it appreciates you can
quickly see it becoming he's going to
keep a i assume based on past uh past
kind of uh performance yeah past
performance and what he's been doing uh
he's going to keep acquiring bitcoin but
if the price appreciates fidelity
setting a presentation we talked about
the other day where it was 100 million
dollars per bitcoin the clients they
sent that right so like there is some uh
belief obviously that this can go much
higher than it currently is and we'll
see but i think that uh his concentrated
bet has put him in a very very very good
position if it does appreciate in value
and he'll be looked at as kind of one of
the uh
this historically will be one to go down
as one of the best trades in history
from a corporate ceo
there are a couple of things that people
have done in the past which i think
folks look at and they're like wow that
was like epic one of them is berkshire
hathaway uh going ahead buying geico and
the insurance companies getting the free
flow being able to invest that capital
very aggressively uh and very well for
decades and decades letting compounding
work and eventually becoming uh one of
the most valuable companies in the world
and warren buffett becoming one of the
richest people in the world right
i think that this is a berkshire
hathaway-like trade
that if it works people will look back
and be like oh my god it was so obvious
what to do uh and we didn't do it
there's the microstrategy stock right
there um again you know closely
following the bitcoin price for the most
part you could see the peak there in
kind of early march or so um and then
eventually kind of coming back down to
about 600 is this a way for people like
do you think if you don't have exposure
to bitcoin don't want um directly to own
it like they should just go have
microstrategy stock in a sense right
because it follows it so well well we've
seen institutions that can't go out and
publicly buy bitcoin they've they've
used microstrategy stock as an option to
go and opt into that market and get
exposure to that asset
but yeah i mean i think like uh it's an
interesting play because you still get
kind of that infrastructure piece that
microstrategy is a real company right
they have real products they have real
revenue they do all that kind of stuff
also uh they've obviously appreciate
their stock is appreciated mostly
because of the bitcoin price over the
past uh 400 days since he's been
acquiring it but yeah they have a real
product they have real revenue and they
have all these things but you get
exposure to that asset class too so if
you're a company uh whether you're a
hedge fund an institutional investor of
some sort and you legally can't or your
company does not allow you to go out and
buy bitcoin the assets specifically this
offers another way of exposure to it and
i think that what we've seen is
microstrategy there's been a premium
place on their stock outside of uh the
bitcoin price uh i don't have a chart
necessarily that overlays it but i've
seen it in the past where like there is
a certain premium that's applied to the
stock because you have that additional
demand from people coming in that don't
just want access to bitcoin they also
like the company but they get the
exposure to bitcoin that which they
wanted anyway so it's kind of an upside
play on the business and the strategy
moving forward if bitcoin continues to
appreciate in price
the other piece of this that to me seems
um
important is that michael saylor is not
simply
doing this with a small portion of the
balance sheet he's doing it with
almost all of it and the reason why i
say that's important is one there's a
severity of conviction but also two is
uh as the stock becomes um you know kind
of more closely tied to bitcoin itself
what you essentially are doing is you
are presenting a uh example of a company
that is now hyper bitcoinization now i
have not talked to michael about this at
all i hold no strategy stock uh
intentionally because uh i i tend to
think that um i would rather have my
friendship with him rather than be a
shareholder but
i gotta think
that if you're
this convicted around bitcoin and you
hold this much bitcoin and you are a
software company that is super into
business intelligence etc
you got to start playing in the bitcoin
space whether it is you're doing mining
whether it is that you're building a
wallet whether it's you're doing some
sort of on-chain metric like something
starts to creep into the business other
than right now they've basically
separated the business they have what
they call their software strategy or
like their business strategy and they
have a treasury strategy and treasury
strategy obviously by bitcoin the
business strategy is to continue to
become an even bigger leader in the
business analytics our business
intelligence and then be able to drive
profit take that profit convert it into
bitcoin etc what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're gonna be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you ten dollars in bitcoin for free
it's that simple head on over to
sofi.com to get started today thanks so
much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]
you